ah Utah the perfect place for
snowmobiling and it's where we meet our
next king of carnage Tim Patton theory
is having fun but in March 2011
Tim's fun was seriously interrupted as I
come up to the top of the hill I give it
a quick blip of the throttle to sink the
rear end
I step off of the sled and boom I feel
that the slope take off and I'm off to
the races down to the trees
[Music]
immediately the snow starts to suck you
under so I was swimming hard to the left
trying to get to the other side of these
trees and I'm feeling like if I don't
miss these trees it's not going to be
good
I feel the initial impact and then
immediately I'm being pushed hard with
hundreds of pounds of snow
both legs wrapped around the trees and
thought for sure my legs were gonna
break right then we didn't know at that
time how badly can was hurt or if he was
even dead so what exactly had Tim and
his snowmobile done to trigger the
ice-cold carnage so on the side of the
mountain it's a battle of gravity versus
friction snow builds up in layers you
get a big layer of thick dense snow and
then another layer of thick dense snow
on top but in between the only thing
keeping them together is a little bit of
a friction there's this whole layer of
snow that just wants to slip down it's
all ready to go it just needs someone
come along on their snowmobile and
trigger
but soon as Tim adds his weight with the
snowmobile it's too much the friction
isn't enough to keep the snow there and
the whole slab starts to slide down the
mountain but can white fluffy snow do
any damage to it tough dude like to him
that wall of snow is equivalent to about
9,000 metric tonnes now that's the
weight of about 14 blue whales and it's
traveling at somewhere between 40 and 60
km/h which is really high speed to have
a blue well coming toppling down on top
of you Tim suffered serious ligament
damage to both knees a small price to
pay for escaping with his life so has
this experience changed Tim's taste for
the white stuff had a three months of
rehab on both knees and I was ready for
the next winter soon as it started snow
and I was ready to go it hasn't changed
me it's too much fun to think about oh
it's too dangerous we like getting far
out and we're looking for a good time
every time we go out
[Music]